[Music]
I'm a
beekeeper I protect the
hive sometimes I use fire to smoke out
Hornets this is a multi-million dollar
operation [__] okay so you can't come
up here white nighting
[__] will you stomp his ass out
please
I got it I got you [__] get him you
[__] get
him but you feel really proud of
yourself you're a blessing Mr Clay this
place was crab grass and weeds and you
brought it back to
life sis Parker and I were friends she
was like family she was the only person
who ever took care of
me I just got a message saying that
there's a problem with my computer yes
ma'am we got
this yesterday she shot herself this is
private property do you know what they
do here scamming the weakest in our
society buddy I'm counter three 1 2
three there I did it for
you no
you I'm going to burn this place to the
ground will you stop his ass
out you're telling me one man did this
the only thing you know is he's a
beekeeper a beekeeper beekeeper well
that's not
good beekeepers is a special program
outside the chain of command I protect
the hive when the system is out of
balance I correct it we have WS for
these things until they fail then you
have
me my fingers they cut them off what the
[__] bro don't
move
bow
down this is much bigger than a little
fishing
scale the money's going all over the
world to people in finance even
government you are a problem God damn
right I'm a
problem no way he's coming to a straight
through the back entrance I figured I'd
give the fir FS a break somebody need to
tame this guy
we have to kill him before he kills his
way to the
top
honey it's flammable as [__] who
knew going
get
[Music]
yeah